she's just so happy to get this
fruit dropping on her from the sky
i don't think i would be
that happy in this situation
wake up sheeple did you know you could
be saving millions of dollars a year
by making your own beauty products
this video is going to tell us how
it's michelle of lab muffin beauty science
here chemistry phd cosmetic chemist and
big fan of diy hacks i love a bargain i love
using what i already have i'm literally filming
this using a rig that involves an old gym
towel i sewed retinol back together by hand
so i try to be generous when i'm looking at
beauty hacks but i think it's fair to say
that most beauty hacks are a bit questionable
today i'm going to be doing a reaction video
there's this compilation of tips from
a facebook page called beauty hacks
that seems to be at least semi-legit they actually
credit their models and everyone which is nice
we're going to be looking at their fruit hacks
like and subscribe for more non-sheeple tips
right so first off almonds aren't fruit they're
seeds i guess this hack would make sense if you
were desperate and you didn't have any black
or brown products lying around but what's the
chance that you don't have that but you do have
an almond and a lighter part of this which makes
me a bit sad is that almonds are pretty expensive
so you can use things other than almonds for this
so if you take any sort of organic material
something that was recently living so for example
i guess wood or bones or i don't know hair
even if you burn it you do get something called
carbon black basically it's just carbon soot it
comes from incomplete combustion which is yeah
even if you get a candle for example so you could
use something a lot cheaper than an almond to do
this as well this hack does essentially give
you pure pigment which sounds like it would be
a good thing because more pigment means more
color but in reality there are lots of other
ingredients in a makeup product that make it
work better so for example eyebrow pencils and
powders usually have other ingredients in there
to help the pigment stick to skin and stay put
and not crease so this hack would work but it
would be like the equivalent of the world's
worst eyebrow product it's the sort of product
where if you actually looked it up you'd see a
million angry reviews about how crap it is you
can actually see in the video that it's not
working that well and i guess with eyebrows it's a
more forgiving area because you don't really want
any sort of solid looking product you do kind of
want an uneven look to make it look more natural
okay so in this hack they're putting together
some really expensive ingredients so we have
pomegranate which currently is $4.50 per
pomegranate at my local supermarket i know because
i went there last night there's cranberry powder
which is $36 for 200 grams which i just looked up
and rose oil which is also stupid expensive it is
360 dollars from doterra if you are into doterra
these are not really things that most people just
have lying around at home and this ends up really
expensive i'm just kind of offended about how
this goes against the whole cheaparse spirit of
diy that i subscribe to this feels kind of like if
gwyneth paltrow decided to make a budget-friendly
diy hack i guess the main appeal is that this
seems kind of natural but there's pretty much no
evidence for any of this really helping acne in
a very general sense most fruits will have some
humectants in them humectants are moisturizing
ingredients that can help hold onto moisture
and keep your skin hydrated which in a roundabout
way could help with acne but not better than any
other moisturizer most natural fruits and stuff
will have antioxidants in them and that is partly
what's giving it that red color and antioxidants
could i guess potentially help with acne
one of the contributors to acne is inflammation
which leads to free radicals which is what
antioxidants can help with sebum which is your
skin's natural oil also tends to thicken up when
it oxidizes and that can lead to clogged pores
but there are so many antioxidants out there
not all of them will get into skin and actually
have the ability to work that's why there aren't
that many antioxidants in skin care the ones that
are in skin care products are the ones that have
a bit more of a proven track record so
in terms of effectiveness this is a very
ehhhhh sort of hack it's not going to be amazing i
don't think it really has any proven acne benefits
it probably won't hurt your skin it will hurt
your wallet i think the reason they've picked
these particular products is that they've just
kind of picked everything that sort of red
and i think the reason for that is that
the red and the dropper kind of looks a
bit like the ordinary's peel that is a super
popular product it is theoretically going
to work a lot better for acne because those
exfoliating acids will help unclog pores and
keep them clear this on the other hand there's
pretty much nothing that will probably work
this is just kind of silly i mean all they're
doing is rubbing a strawberry on their teeth
i'm pretty sure using a toothbrush with just
water would work better there's also the fact
that strawberries have sugar in them and
they also have a low ph which is acidic
and so you are basically kind of getting worse
than using a toothbrush with water you have
sugar and acid and that is not going to be great
for your teeth it probably won't be super harmful
it is pretty similar to just eating fruit
but it's also not better than just water
the acting in this is kind of hilarious like she
looks so happy to have that
orange drop out of the sky
all right so we obviously have orange peel
here oranges make us think of vitamin c
and obviously vitamin c ascorbic acid is a
really useful skincare ingredient that has a
lot of evidence behind it however ascorbic acid is
water-soluble pretty much all of the vitamin c in
an orange is in the juice not in the peel i guess
what they're using here then is orange essential
oil instead which has a few ingredients in it
that could potentially be beneficial for skin
but also a bunch that are usually irritating
they've also got yogurt and honey in there
and both of these can be hydrating for your skin
yogurt i think tends to get overused in these diy
skincare recipes and the reason i think is because
yogurt has lactic acid in it lactic acid is used
in chemical exfoliants it's an alpha hydroxy acid
and it helps skin turn over faster so you get
fresher skin you get more smoother skin
you get more glowy skin it can also reduce
clogged pores lactic acid is also used for fading
hyperpigmentation but the problem here is that
yogurt only has about one percent usually in most
skincare products you'll get at least about four
percent usually quite a bit higher usually in the
double digits if you want to target pigmentation i
also think honey is overused in diy recipes honey
has a reputation for being antibacterial but again
it is a bit overblown especially if
you're mixing it with other things
most of the antibacterial properties of honey
is because it's really concentrated it's really
sugary it doesn't have a lot of water in it
and so it's got what we call low water activity
that means that if you have a microbe in there
with a relatively thin membrane around it
then the rest of that sugar is going to suck
out the water from the microbe and kill it
and yeah that's how it works some specific honeys
also have some phytochemicals in them these are
plant chemicals so for example manuka honey has
a whole bunch that have antibacterial activity
and the ones that have certified activity will
usually have a label on them but when you have
some random honey and it's being diluted into a
diy product and it's only left on your skin for
five minutes it's probably not going to have any
big antibacterial effect it could be hydrating
turmeric is also really popular in diy recipes
because turmeric has curcumin in it and this
is an antioxidant there is some evidence that
curcumin can help fade pigment but the evidence
is pretty weak it's not as strongly backed as a
lot of other skincare ingredients that we commonly
use for fading pigment you do also tend to need
heaps of turmeric to get enough curcumin to make a
difference not just a pinch and turmeric is bright
yellow so it can actually stain your face if you
don't wash it off properly and just sometimes for
a couple of days after you use it so turmeric and
curcumin isn't really used that much in skincare
because of that issue and this just looks like
it's going to be less effective than a regular
skincare product formulated with curcumin in it
she's just so happy to get this
fruit dropping on her from the sky
i don't think i would be
that happy in this situation
so what she's really doing here is rubbing
watermelon ice on her face to try to de-puff it
and this will actually work because cold works
the watermelon juice isn't really doing anything
here so this can be done even more cheaply you
can use ice cubes you can use a cold bag of
frozen vegetables one trick i've heard from makeup
artists is that you can actually use a teaspoon so
you just put some teaspoons into the fridge and
then let them cool down and then rub them on your
face and that's really reusable and i would say
a better diy hack in my spirit of cheaparseness
so this hack is really just using lemon juice and
sugar to exfoliate the armpits darkness in the
armpits is sometimes from a buildup of skin and so
exfoliating can help lighten it also if you have
pigment exfoliation can lighten pigment so sugar
is a physical exfoliant and that part is fine
physical exfoliants the roughness really depends
on how hard you press so if you press very gently
it can be very gentle on skin i also quite
like sugar because it dissolves a bit in
water and that means that it can become
a bit less harsh the lemon juice though
is a bit dangerous so lemon juice does contain
vitamin c again vitamin c ascorbic acid
is a really useful skincare ingredient
it's used a lot in fading pigment
it could also increase collagen in your skin
and it's also an antioxidant which could prevent
future pigment production lemon juice also has
citric acid which is an alpha hydroxy acid which
is a chemical exfoliant again just like with
lactic acid this can help exfoliate the skin and
possibly lighten pigmentation the problem is you
have so little of these chemicals in lemon juice
that it probably won't make a big difference so
there's 0.4% ascorbic acid in lemon juice which is
really low for ascorbic acid usually you're
looking at somewhere between 5 and 20 percent
the biggest problem with lemon juice though is
something called phytophotodermatitis and this is
when you go into the sun and some of the chemicals
in the lemon juice particularly in the lemon peel
can make your skin super sensitive to the sun
and so if you go out there with that on your skin
you can actually end up with like a blistering
sunburn which is just really nasty and painful
not to mention it will make your skin more
inflamed and that will actually cause more
pigment so it'll be counterproductive with armpits
you're probably not exposing them a ton to the sun
but if you are trying to lighten them i'm assuming
that you're planning to have people see them
maybe you're going into summer and you will
actually get sun exposure there is also one
side effect that can potentially happen if you use
too much lemon juice and that's called chemical
leukoderma and this is where some patches of
your skin will actually lighten the pigment
producing cells will actually die off and so you
end up with abnormally light skin in those bits
this is usually not very even and so again
it's kind of counterproductive if you're
trying to even out your skin you probably
don't want permanent light patches on there
so i actually don't mind this hack kiwi fruit
has an enzyme in it called actinidin which acts
a bit like that papaya enzyme or the pumpkin
enzyme which is an enzyme exfoliant so it
will actually help detach dead skin from your
feet enzyme exfoliants also tend to be quite
gentle compared to chemical and physical
exfoliants this also has sugar in it again
that is a physical exfoliant and it works really
well because it's rough when you dissolve it
a bit in water it can make it a little bit
smaller which means that'll be a bit gentler
but in this hack it looks like they've left it for
too long so it looks like it's dissolved and it's
just turned into a syrup which means it's not
going to do very much i guess it will hydrate
skin because sugar is a good humectant sugars
in terms of chemistry sorry this is a bit nerdy
but sugars have a lot of oh groups on them
if you look back here i have my glycerin
glycerin also has those oh groups there that's
the o and that's the h and that's the reason why
they're really good humectants those grab onto
water kiwi probably also has humectants in it
including sugars and so that's going to hydrate
the feet but again in the spirit of cheaparsery
i'm going to recommend instead getting the kiwi
fruit skin so eat the kiwi fruit use that up
and then take the skins and then maybe dip that
into sugar and rub it on your feet sort of like
the lemon hack except with a slightly better fruit
alternatively if you want a really effective way
of just blasting all the dead skin off your feet
i would recommend a product like baby foot this
has chemical exfoliants in it and after you
soak your feet in them your feet will just
shed skin for days it's very disgusting and very
satisfying and they're usually not that expensive
so i hope you enjoyed this beauty hacks reaction
video i haven't done one of these for a while
so if you enjoyed it let me know and if you
have other videos you want me to react to
leave them in the comments as well like and
subscribe and click the nerdification bell
if you like talking about the science
behind beauty you can also follow me
on all of the platforms and i will see you soon
hopefully we'll get some better hacks next time